voulez-vous que nous intéressions
quelques minutes à edouard snowden vous
vous souvenez cet homme qui était
employé de la haine et salle agence de
sécurité nationale américaine
en 2013 il a dénoncé un vaste système de
surveillance des américains système qui
considéré comme abusif à la suite de
ces dénonciations il est parti en russie
il aimerait bien maintenant venir en
france et ils demandent c'est d'ailleurs
pas la première fois l'asile politique à
la france
il l'a répété ce matin sur france inter
je vais demander l'asile en france en
2013 de françois hollande
j'aimerais beaucoup que ce matériau la
corde c'est pas la france c'est le monde
c'est le système dans lequel on vit près
serge et les lanceurs d alerte c'est pas
un acte qui est terrible c'est pas une
attaque contre les états unis
c'est une main tendue qu'un amitié
annoncé ça le sujet est une attaque
contre les états unis que d'accueillir
edouard cela nous rappellera que ce
dernier est inculpée d'espionnage et de
vol de secrets d'état aux états unis en
tout cas il y à des personnalités
proches des manuels macro qui sont
plutôt favorables à l'asile politique
pour edward se donne par exemple nicole
belloubet encore elles dont je vous
rappelle qu'elle était l'invité du grand
jury pour ou contre nicole belloubet
accorder l'asile aux lanceurs d'alerté
edouard snowdon qui le réclament à la
france bon contre nicole ménard pourrait
y en a qui répondent tour aussi mais de
façon un petit peu plus développés c'est
nathalie oiseaux la députée européenne
c'est à l'ofpra de reprendre la nouvelle
demande d'asile puisque je comprends
qu'un à une d'edouard standen à titre
personnel je ne vois pas ce qu'est leur
stand n fait en russie un des pays les
plus habitués à la surveillance de masse
et la manipule et vous vous dites après
tout est-ce qu'ils soient en europe
aujourd'hui ce que je constate c'est que
aucun pays européen n'a donné l'asile
est en deuil non je pense qu'on est en
décalage complet par rapport aux valeurs
comporte donc vous dites il faudrait
l'accueillir absolument on hâte et
l'oiseau qui on s'en souvient a été la
tête de liste en marche aux élections
européennes est-ce que accueillir
snowdon se fâcher avec les états unis
andré bercoff je rappelle que vous êtes
le seul journaliste français a jamais
avoir interviewé le
trump je crois que je crois que le
problème donc pourquoi il est allé en
russie d'abord parce qu'effectivement
les états unis étaient c'était bien
avant trup était fou de rage de ce qu'il
a révélé ces faits en 2013 absolument
c'est de mieux guillaume je voudrais
quand même rappeler quelque chose il ya
un autre lanceur d alerte ou moins aussi
connu que snowden qui pourrit dans une
prison aujourd'hui qui est julian
assange
je trouve que le sort réservé julian
assange est lamentable je dis c'est là
on peut être pour ou contre ce qu'il a
fait il était comme vous savez pendant
sept ans dans une chambre de l'ambassade
équatorienne à londres il est on l'a
fait sortir et il est aujourd'hui en
prison à les neiges du bon alors qu'est
ce que ça veut dire les lanceurs de l'
alerte
moi je trouve que franchement la france
je vous dirai ça n'aurait en tout cas il
pourrait vraiment accueillir et de
garden et même d'ailleurs julian assange
sans être déshonneur et je trouve ça les
lanceurs d alerte quand même il ya eu
des choses qui ont été révélées qui
était fondamental c'est pas un casus
belli avec les américains sur mon port
sûrement pas pas avec trump bon donc
vous êtes plutôt pourrait bien on va
continuer le tournoi mais avant je vais
vous donner la vie de nos internautes
la france doit-elle accorder l'asile à
edouard snowdon et bien il ya une
majorité 60% qui répondent positivement
à cette question c'est une autre
question posée aujourd'hui sur
lefigaro.fr il y a dix mille sept cent
trente de votants aux dernières
nouvelles 62 il a même eu 30 de plus
depuis que j'ai pris mes notes et voit
une foule d'amis pour contre l'asile
politique
ça serait plutôt une bonne chose
c'est effectivement je ne connais pas
assez bien la psychologie de trump je
sais pas qui la connaît bien d'ailleurs
pour savoir si ça l'embellie pour savoir
si ça aurait des influences mais c'est
vrai que ce qui l'a révélé et quand même
nous a permis
quand même à une petite échelle d'ouvrir
les yeux sur le monde dans lequel on
avait basculé
donc ne serait ce que pour ça parce que
c'est une a été une sentinelle quelqu'un
qui a dit bon en étant bien placé pour
le dire que que finalement la plupart
des citoyens américains étaient été
espionnées sans le savoir donc bon oui
ça serait ça serait ça serait bien que
la france l'accueille et peter sur
twitter est tout à fait d'accord avec
vous chers en bulgarie nous dit il faut
remercier snowdon le soutenir
l'accueillir lui donner des
responsabilités à la dgse les nous a
montré à quel point les états unis nous
écoute et nous lisent arnaud benedetti
votre point de vue oui de son système de
surveillance à l'échelle planétaire la
nsa et c'était très connue c'était très
connue de certains nombre d'ingénieurs
de technologues de scientifiques qui de
militaires qui savent très bien à
l'efficacité de ce système
en effet la france honoré je suis assez
d'accord à le recevoir
le problème c'est que si vous laissez
pas seulement 30 le problème c'est que
les états unis ces tunnels sont souvent
pas mal d'ailleurs c'était les états
unis c'est une pole hier chili à une
administration et c'est vrai une poly
archi c'est à dire que c'est un système
avec différents acteurs qui poursuivent
qui construisent le pouvoir et comme
d'ailleurs beaucoup de démocratie le
système américain est quand même très
équilibré sur le plan des institutions
il faut jamais l'oublier beaucoup plus
équilibré que le nôtre vraisemblablement
ce qui fait que trump a peut-être moins
de pouvoirs que macron dans son propre
pays mais la réalité c'est que c'est ça
c'est que ces sept
cette administration peut-être qu'ils
s'opposeraient semblablement mais
certainement pas la personnalité de
trempe à mon sens ce qui constitue
l'obstacle majeur aujourd'hui à
l'accueil en marge de la même chose pour
assange
mais quand même que sa toile à cet homme
il poursuivi dans son pays
avant ça il n'a pas encore été jugé mais
est-ce que c'est pas faire obstruction à
la justice américaine que de lui
accorder l'asile politique que les
russes le fasse on peut comprendre mais
nous c'est moins évident
et pas évident parce que si on réfléchit
au fondement de la construction des pays
européens après la guerre si on
réfléchit à la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme la protection de la
vie privée est fondamentale et c'est
vraiment et pourquoi on l'a on l'a mis
au coeur du projet européen d'après à la
cod h s'applique tout simplement parce
que on avait peur que 1984 le film le
livre d'orwell deux 48 se passe on avait
peur que on est à nouveau des régimes de
type totalitaire nazis fascistes etc
et donc c'est vraiment le fondement de
l'idée et des démocraties européennes
d'après guerre qui est en cause et donc
c'est notre identité même est ce que
snow dunn a mis en avant ses trois
choses premièrement la surveillance de
masse à la 1984 c'est possible par les
états deuxièmement il y à des entreprise
titanesque qu'on appelle les gars femmes
il n'y a pas que les gars femmes qui y
contribuent et troisièmement vous avez
besoin parce que l'état ne vous protège
plus de trouver vos propres moyens de
protection et donc ça c'est ça serait
bien aussi que monsieur bellamy s'y
intéresse c'est une remise en question
fondamentale de l'identité de nos
sociétés à partir de là je pense que si
on veut conserver notre identité c'est
fondamental et il faut accorder le droit
d'asile à ce type qui a un courage
incroyable parce que la machinerie la
violence de la machine américaine
extraordinaire et il s'est retrouvé
vraiment seul et c'est une honte pour
nos démocraties de ne pas avoir été
capable de l'accueillir
et c'est comme ça qu'il ya une
contradiction démocratique et que on
affaiblit la démocratie même doit en
revanche ils ne jouent pas ce qu'on va
très bien ce qui se passe sur twitter et
facebook
dans la censure et est donc le vrai
courage il est là mais le vrai courage
c'est aussi d'avoir un vrai débat
politique sur ce sujet c'est à voir
comme les chinois nos propres
infrastructures
numérique c'est quand même fou de savoir
qu'on ait observé par les américains
plus que les américains observent les
chinois ou les russes
nous sommes le premier temps mais c'est
vrai nom mais si c'est vrai il suffit
simplement nous observer autant que nous
offrir du chinois mais mais mais tout
simplement parce que il ya les
infrastructures et à la facilité il ya
des secrets économique qui a des vraies
stars et donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on
rebaptise le lien transatlantique en
remettant les vrais sujets le sujet des
valeurs au coeur est temps qu'on le fait
pas qu'est ce qu'il va se passer c'est
un éloignement systématique organisé de
la route de l'europe et des états unis
et ce n'est bon pour personne ni les et
pour les américains ni pour les
européens feraient qu'on ait le courage
nous mêmes de mettre ce sujet
fondamental à l'ordre du jour il n'est
pas évident pourtant que ça se fasse un
soldat on se souvient de françois
hollande avait refusé de donner l'asile
politique à stodden hélas après les
déclarations de ce week-end convient
d'écouter
il ya eu un communiqué pour dire que
voilà le gouvernement français n'avait
pas de position officielle pour
accueillir ce modèle le l'amitié franco
américaine va avant nos principes
peut-être peut-être oui parce que
effectivement je vous passiez tout à
l'heure le témoignage de madame l'oiseau
qui dit c'est que il des brevets de
suivre une procédure en déposant sa
candidature à l'afp ram ccc apprend
rappelle ainsi la vidéo officielle
il est instruit les demandes d'asile
voilà quand même le risible quoi enfin
quand quand on a la cia j éminemment
sera que politiques dire qu'ils vont
passer par le fera encore assez mais
déçu par même louer donc c'est vrai que
là c'est assez étonnant
ça serait oui ça serait quoi marque de
courage politique que finalement l'asile
lui soit accordé ce qui serait bien
c'est qu'il est aussi il ya tellement de
mouvement sur les réseaux sociaux en
faveur ou contre pour des guérillas
parfois insignifiantes et finalement
pourquoi pas qu'il ya un mouvement
d'opinion qui secret pour pour accorder
l'asile à monsieur snowdon mais est ce
qu'on a vraiment un mouvement d'opinion
parce que après tout c'est ces
révélations n'ont rien changer au
système américain les gens sont toujours
écouté il semblerait que ils mettent
leur sécurité avant l'heure yvan lors il
est bien qu'un lanceur de l'air qui ne
va pas changer changer la chose on est
plus à rien de licharre stop
mais moi je suis extrêmement rappelé
rappelez moi qui c'était parce que je ne
sais la case de l'oncle tom à un livre
qui avait changé est vraiment en partie
la condition d' esclavage aux biens
décennies la chose quand même c'est
qu'on accueille beaucoup de gens en
france très bien d'accueil rouge à
l'accueil des gens quelquefois qui
franchement ne mériterait pas d'être
accueilli et je ne comprends pas encore
que après que ça fasse problème qu'est
ce qui va faire ce modèle il va pas je
veux dire yves à quoi il va nous faire
que les relations entre l'amérique et
l'europe et la france vont être rompu
sûrement pas c'est à dire que c'est une
question à la fois des tic de symbolique
et c'est je pense qu'on est extrêmement
timide et je dirais à passer peu
courageux sur la question et je dirais
même plus c'est que aux états unis il ya
ce qu'on a beaucoup de supporters et il
ya des mouvements de jean la silicon
valley qui se sont organisés justement
pour contrer
je vais dire à la fois le le
les risques liés à ce que l'état pénètre
du privé aussi le risque délégué phare
et là il ya des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui s'organise qui font de la
pédagogie
je trouve qu'en europe la réflexion est
beaucoup moins mûrs qu'elle ne l'est
quelques années aux états unis et puis
l'autre sujet d'ailleurs ça c'est que
les gaffes à pompe la publicité qui
nourrissait notre écosystème médiatique
et que notre article et google et
facebook
rêverie 80% la la publicité numérique
c'est google et facebook consent %
peut-être dans deux ou cinq ans et ça
c'est un affaissement de notre système
d'information qui est au coeur à la fois
de notre système économique pour avoir
une information de qualité et notre vie
démocratique et je pense qu'il faut ces
défis sont des défis vraiment urgence et
pas des défis a dit à 10 ans j'allais
bien une chose ça ça je ne sais pas si
on pourra faire quelque chose la chose
la plus importante c'est les gens qui se
mobilisent en amérique je mens sur la
loi antitrust en utilisant la loi
antitrust en disant qu'à son le trust de
facebook et de google ça le problème
tant que c'est un trust devait faire du
rock quoi faisait pas contents nous en
irlande et à comment l'europe peut rien
faire être subtil europe et a passé en
sélection on peut faire des choses
pasqua il faut qu'on ait à hanover mais
non mais il faut qu'on crée un
régulateur numérique européen qui puisse
avoir accès aux données des dégâts parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans la
possibilité de faire jouer lentilles
trois semaines crée c'est que c'est à
l'union européenne
madame voir vous madame goulard et
madame vous de l'ocs
voilà c'est un oiseau aussi peut-être
qu'ils vous à le faire là où elle est au
parlement européen